relatively early in president Trump's
Administration Mark Meadows and I this
before Mark was Chief of Staff we're in
the white house and we're visiting
someone in the west wing and one of the
offices I may have been Jared's officer
somebody's office but they had a big
white board on the wall
and they had listed every single promise
president Trump made to the American
people in the 2016 campaign
and they were just I mean it was packed
get out of the Iran deal Embassy in
Jerusalem build the wall uh get out of
Paris climate Accords conservatives on
the court cut taxes reduce regulation
just it was packed because he made a lot
of important promises
um and they were checking them off
just literally checking them
that's how you're supposed to go yeah
what'd you tell the people you're going
to do if they give you the privilege of
representing and serving them and
leading them go do what you said and no
one's done it better
DC
enjoying me today people laugh just when
you say DC is the congressman for Ohio's
fourth district who just won his
re-election by a landslide he also
serves as the ranking member of the
House Judiciary Committee and is a
co-founder of the House Freedom caucus
Congressman Jim Jordan good to see you
nice to be with you good to be a
congratulations on all your great work
and success we appreciate what you do
thank you well I'm just trying to uh
save the country like like God bless you
it's a great country and it's greatest
country ever it's worth saving it's
worth fighting for and and so thank you
for doing that well I appreciate that
first off I have to ask you why aren't
your sleeves rolled up yeah
it's not as hot in DC as it normally is
here and so uh yeah it's uh sometimes I
own a Committee hearing when when that
witness is from the government and you
know they have not been square with the
people I get to represent sometimes you
got to roll up your sleeves so you can
really get after them because they
deserve it a lot of time in my judgment
a lot of times like a faucy guy you know
how many different how many things the
palsy tells that we're not true pretty
much everything yeah exactly pretty much
everything exactly you see the piece in
the in I think it was the Atlantic like
two weeks ago let's all just yeah like
you're right yeah like let's just all
get along and not worry about those
things that said that you know shut down
the economy cost people their jobs let
people not go see their mom or dad in a
nursing home and maybe they they were on
their deathbed or something like crazy
stuff that this guy did to us oh let's
just forget it and I'm not like it's not
about holding a grudge it's about
accountability so it doesn't happen
again and that guy uh anyway I didn't
even mean to get started on that but for
some reason I thought about it like what
the heck well all right we can get to
some of that stuff but I have to ask the
first thing I have to ask you is when I
booked this trip to DC we knew we were
doing it right after the election we
thought the Red Wave was a coming it's a
trickle at best we still are unclear
exactly where the house is going to end
up Senate is not looking great we'll see
what happens with the Georgia thing all
that but clearly the Republican party
which I think should be doing much
better better than it is is is in this
strange state of flux what is going on
here
well look the positive is I do think
we're going to win the house it looks
like 219 220 maybe 221
um so anything 218 or up is is when and
and winning beats losing every time I
learned that a long time ago
um so that's the positive
um but you're right we thought it was
going to be more I do think um I was
talking with a conservative reporter who
I have a great deal of respect for and
she said that we're going to have to
we're going to have to do the ballot
harvesting the the the mail-in voting
routine as good as they do because you
know we won the popular vote yep
um 50 some million to 47 men whatever
that's good but it was like I think it's
about a 5 million difference yeah so
5247 something like that so which is
great and and turnout was up compared to
2018 midterm
so something's going right there but we
lost so many close ones in these States
where there's a huge mail-in vote it
seems like we lost all of them and the
one incumbent we kept in Nevada but we
thought we could win any of those three
uh seats and and lack salt Senate race
we didn't win AO so we're gonna have to
do something different there Washington
State Oregon California Arizona these
States where there's such a mail-in but
is it possible to do and well first off
do you want to do the exact same tactics
as them because generally people on
let's say are so I don't like these
tactics right we like to show up and
vote and feel that paper trail and all
of that so that's no that trust me it
was I I did it in Florida this time
where I had to show an ID and a piece of
paper it was a pleasure as opposed to
Cali where if you show an ID they'll
basically arrest you on the spot but so
that they're do you want to really like
like sort of philosophically do we want
to do all the shenanigans that they do
that's number one and then number two
can it be fixed in these places that are
so calcified blue where what what
Machinery can actually go in there and
fix it Well it can't like I mean you
can't change the law to something like
in Ohio like you're in Florida we're in
Ohio how's the same thing you walk in
show your ID there's two Democrats
sitting there two Republicans show your
ID oh yeah you're Jim Jordan there's a
voter registration thing find your name
flip it around you sign it signature
match give you a ballot color in the
people you want to vote for paper trail
in a machine results exactly the same as
Florida it was great so we get our
results just like Florida at 10 30 at
night yeah so California is not going to
change because Democrats run everything
and they got super majorities in their
legislature
um so they're never going to change
their law to like what we have and and
where it makes sense in Florida in Ohio
um so I think you just sort of have to
and I get it I did the same way I put on
Election Day I think you're just gonna
have to say like the rules have changed
like my background's wrestling if the
rules change in wrestling you got to
adapt to the rules like okay takedown's
worth too if they're worth worth three
and change what a reversible it's like
okay we gotta you gotta readjust your
strategy I think the same thing applies
here in those States
and again it's still going to be tough
on on Republicans because you know a lot
of times Republican voters are more
rural voters so to show up at people's
homes is different in rural Central
Valley of California than it is in
apartment buildings in San Francisco to
to to to you know take balance of people
and and get their votes so I think we're
going to have to what do we do about
that disconnect you know when they show
you the map of the country right now the
country geographically is like 80
percent red and then of course you have
the big cities that are blue yeah I
don't think that disconnect can hold
forever because people are people are
getting really frustrated with that yeah
you know you live in the places where
they grow the food and you're fighting
for resources with the people in the big
city right right it's our chief of staff
has a great line he says you know West
Central North Central Ohio the the great
District I get to represent
um we make things grow things move
things and I always tell you know people
on the coast who can work remote and and
you know sit at home in Northern in
Virginia drinking their 15 cup of coffee
harassing the truck driver and the
manufacturer and the small business
owner in Lima Ohio like I get it and it
is frustrating so
um and of course the mainstream press is
all the people you know working remote
you can't remote work the crops in right
you gotta you gotta go out and plant the
crops it's like so it is a frustrating
thing I hope we can come together at
some point because it is so divisive
it's like we had this huge election
millions and millions and millions of
dollars maybe billions of dollars spent
um probably was billion because McCarthy
Kevin was like
I think he raised like half a million
himself and from it so billions spent
and we basically looks like we're going
to almost be status quo we're going to
get the house but Senate's gonna maybe
even go down I think Herschel is going
to win in Georgia
um but we so we're going to be the same
result are you okay with the the
splitting of the states in that you know
I saw something just the other morning
that it's something like in the last
three years about 500 000 people have
left New York now a huge percentage of
them end up in Florida they vote red
Florida becomes more red and then
unfortunately New York becomes more blue
Kathy Hotel only won New York by about
330 000 votes those people stay yeah
right and we get Lee Zone who I think
has a huge future yeah what do you think
about him because he did something that
pretty much nobody thought could be done
and very few people knew who he was a
month ago I got to know Lee during the
first impeachment there were four of us
who who were in almost every deposition
we were actually down in the bunker in
the basement of the Capitol I think more
than Adam Schiff was because it was it
was Scott Perry Mark Meadows Lee and
myself and then our our staff lawyers
Steve caster and our team
um Lee's a good man smart guy and and
again it's the other thing I think is
important he was a good disciplined
candidate about talking about the things
New Yorkers cared about and I would
argue his his intense and and quality
race that he ran
uh is is a big reason why we picked up
so many seats I think New York flip
forces yeah right right and and uh so uh
you know we we tweeted out God bless Liz
Elden after we we started winning a
bunch of those New York seats yeah I
think he's got a bright future in our
party and is a good man with a good
family
um and what he went through in that
campaign God bless him it's tough I mean
he literally attacked on stage but what
do you think about the states kind of
going their their separate ways in in
some sense no it's it's Americans
Americans but you know because remember
our remember our it's in our DNA uh when
when we started this place over in
Europe they said you got to practice
your faith a certain way and they said
no we don't
by golly we're going to get on the ship
brisk it all go to this place where you
know we call America and we're going to
do it the way we think the good Lord
wants us to and we're going to have our
goals and our dreams and we're going to
make them happen and and people in New
York where they're getting they're being
attacked and on all kinds of things and
all the left things they're like well
forget this noise I'm going to go to
Florida I'm gonna go to Texas I'm gonna
go to Nashville I'm going to Tennessee
um so yeah you see that happening
um
you can't blame Americans because like I
said I think that's kind of in our kind
of in our DNA to some degree yeah uh
they we naturally crave freedom and
they're going to places where you can
experience Freedom yeah are you uh but
it is this may be concerned because it's
tough then to ever win are we ever going
to get California back it's probably
going to take a whole generation and
maybe it's going to get it's sad to say
but maybe maybe when it gets even worse
in these places maybe then people see
the light and say okay time out we just
can't take it anymore and we sort of
thought that was going to happen Tuesday
and it did to a little to a smaller
degree I think I've asked every
Republican that I've had on the show
this so I've probably asked you this
question at least once or twice before
but when you talk to your Democrat
counterparts do they honestly believe
that the policies they're implementing
are working
or do they just believe you know the the
sort of cynical view would be that they
just believe it's keeping them in power
because they're giving people stuff and
it's working I think the ones who are
still sort of open-minded and not just
totally left-wing radicals I think they
they think like yeah this is well even
Maloney said this week that you know the
the after he lost his race in New York
he I think I saw what he said uh
something like this whole defund the
police movement is crazy you know well
we haven't heard a Democrats say that
for for three years uh but he finally
did and he happened to be the the guy
running the Democrat campaign apparatus
so
um I think deep down some of them know
it but remember the left controls that
party yeah the left controls that party
and there was a survey done two months
ago
Democrats asking Democrats and 55
percent of Democrats said they do not
think America is the greatest nation
ever
that's frightening you got a majority of
one of the two major political parties
in this country that doesn't believe
what
you and I know to be fact greatest
country I've traveled I've been to I
Wrestled in the Soviet Union I was I
went to Cuba in 1988 1990 you go to
places like that you thank the good Lord
you live here everyone still wants to
come here nobody's leaving nobody's
leaving so that's that that's the
control that's the power in their party
and a bunch of the folks in Congress buy
into that idea that America somehow
I mean America is the greatest country
ever it's not perfect but it's the
greatest and they just don't see it that
way do you do you think that that just
got strengthened within their party
because they didn't really suffer any
massive setbacks so now it's like well
we can kind of keep going with that
stuff right Joe Biden said it Joe Biden
said what are you changing nothing
nothing like okay so you want you want
the people you're supposed to be leading
and representing the American people you
want them to continue to pay five
dollars for gas you want them to
continue to pay a 41 year high inflation
rate you want them to continue to have
crime you want to continue to have a
border that's no longer a border I mean
really you want to continue to see the
Constitution attack by your justice
department but that's what I mean about
the cynical version that's not very
cynical I think they're looking at all
that and going man these people must be
idiots because they keep voting for us
or or whatever they're doing with the
harvesting and everything else there's
been no uh no price to pay
they're they're I mean yes I wish
they're going to lose the house they're
going to lose the house I'm confident of
that today so what are you guys going to
do let's get into some of that quick
okay so you get the house now maybe you
can do some hearings about some things
you've led the charge on a lot of the
big Tech stuff it sort of feels like a
lot of that is now in the past that
people aren't even thinking of it as an
issue anymore maybe and maybe in a good
sense in that elon's now come in Twitter
feels like it'll be a little fair
so that's good but but does anything
come of these hearings beyond the
moments you know you now someone or Rand
Paul Nails fouchy on this and it
shouldn't be about that it should be
about the facts yeah it should be about
the American people part of our
constitutional Duty we take the oath of
office on January 3rd part of our duty
is to get the do oversight so the
country knows the truth they deserve
that so I'm committed to doing that in
an aggressive way and I think when you
do that hopefully it begins to slow down
some of these agencies and the things
they're doing that I think are just flat
out wrong and again we've seen some
unprecedented things happen 14 will
whistleblowers come talk to us we shoot
a thousand page report a week and a half
ago that thousand page report highlights
how political the place has become the
justice department one FBI agent and
again he's talking about not the rank
and file but the people at the
Washington field office one fa agent who
came to us as a whistleblower said the
FBI at its at its top at the Washington
field office at its leadership level
rotted to the core direct quote I mean
you've got an agent who's given his life
to this agency saying it's rotted to the
court at its leadership level that
should tell us something so
um and then the negative reaction we got
from the mainstream press on this report
tells us where I mean it's always a good
sign when the Washington Post is
attacking you that's usually a good
thing
um what do you make of this report that
was leaked about how the administration
for sure or at least the intelligence
services for sure were working with big
Tech to silence people I mean we they
had admitted it saki admitted it
remember we flagged posts for Facebook
but now they're like we have the
evidence but the question is and I think
everyone said no wait okay well is
anything going to happen yeah I get that
question and I mean if it's frustrating
for you and I who follow this stuff
imagine just American citizens who are
busy running their business and
volunteering at church and going to
little league and soccer games and
imagine what it's like for them so that
is frustrating to all of us
um I always point out to them though all
we can do is get the facts out there
um at some point you got to have have
you got to have a justice department
that's willing to prosecute people for
if you've got the government actively
pressuring press
pressuring these these social media
platforms to restrict information and
they're doing it for purely partisan
political advantage that is a total
violation of the First Amendment totally
wrong and those people should be held
accountable but I don't know that this
justice department will do it right you
may remember I had a tweet in July of
2021 saying that vaccine mandates were
coming the vaccines aren't working as
promised and in essence we should pause
and think about it and I got banned and
the question from Twitter the question
is saying it though the question is was
that pressure that someone in in the
administration get on the phone and call
uh then she's then a direct violation of
my first amendment maybe he was he maybe
he already left but whoever did he call
Twitter did he call Zuckerberg I mean we
know fauci was Texan and emailing with
uh with Zuckerberg so yeah or someone
else I mean remember to you mentioned
jinsaki I I'm watching
so jinsaki in the White House Press Room
this is a this is I don't know six eight
months ago Jin's talking I think about
the White House is the center of freedom
for considered like the beacon of
freedom on the in the world and you're
in the White House in The Press Room In
The West Wing and the Press spokesperson
for the president United States Jin's
hockey standing at the podium in The
Press Room and she says most Americans
get their news from social media
platforms we're working with those
social media platforms to understand and
limit what Americans see and I literally
saw that live and I'm like
but again there's no price to pay him
and she just gets a six-figure deal at
MSNBC this big shot at MSNBC so all
right we only got about three minutes
left uh so I'm gonna ask you the big one
which I'm sure is the one that you don't
want to talk about probably but last
time I had you on you said that you
absolutely would support Donald Trump if
he runs we're taping this on on Monday
it sounds like he might make some sort
of announcement tomorrow but you can
already feel what's really going on here
which is that the entire machine wants
to set this up as some sort of trump
DeSantis you know Battle Royal and then
just destroy everybody kind of thing
what do you make of what the future of
the party will be and is there a way to
do a fight out in the open that that
leaves Republicans kind of okay at the
end if if DeSantis even wants to run I
don't know look I'm for president Trump
I think he's the best president we've
had and certainly in my lifetime maybe
ever just did more of what he said he
was going to do than
than any president I've ever seen and he
did it with everyone in this town
against him every Democrat everyone in
the mainstream press every you know half
the Republicans and all the bureaucracy
and in spite of that got more done than
you know and I used to just go down
there's an amazing list of things yeah
no
um so I'm president Trump I think he's
the leaderboard party I want him to run
again the speech he gave Monday night
before the election in our state yeah
unbelievable unbelievable
um what a leader
um so I'm for him yeah but Ron DeSantis
look there was there were nine of us who
formed the freedom caucus seven years
ago Rahm was one of the original nine
and he's done a great job as Governor
but um do you think there's a way to
have it out with the two of them without
really irreparably damaging somebody
because policy wise they're both now in
it but that that means it's going to
have to get to something else that's
going to be pretty dirty probably look I
I I hope I hope it's president Trump
um and I'd prefer he Ron you know keep
running Florida and then listen I love
Florida I feel like I'm going to win
either way here and then run for
president uh he's got plenty of time but
but that that'll be his decision but uh
no matter what I'm going to be for
president Trump I think he was the kind
of leader that we need and if there's a
competition then you know we're the
party competition voters will decide
um and and you know God Bless America I
always
you know like I said my background's
wrestling you got to win the semifinals
where you get to wrestle in the finals
that's just the way the tournament goes
and um but I think I think
I still remember this is early
relatively early in president Trump's
Administration Mark Meadows and I just
before Mark was Chief of Staff we're in
the white house and we're visiting
someone in the west wing and one of the
offices there may have been Jared's
officer somebody's office but they had a
big white board on the wall
and they had listed every single promise
president Trump made to the American
people in the 2016 campaign
and they were just I mean it was packed
get out of the Iran deal Embassy in
Jerusalem build the wall uh get out of
Paris climate Accords conservatives on
the court cut taxes reduce regulation
just
it was packed because he made a lot of
important promises
um and they were checking them off
just literally checking with it that's
how you're supposed to go yeah what'd
you tell the people you're going to do
if they give you the privilege of
representing and serving them and
leading them go do what you said and no
one's done it better and and then people
say well yeah but you know some of the
things I think that toughness is is the
only attitude that can work in this town
when you look at how bad the mainstream
press is how mean the left is how how
vicious the cancel culture is you've got
to have someone as tough As Trump to
deal with all that that's why I'm for it
it's funny I used to always people would
always say you know well I I like him
but you know the tweets the tweets and I
would always say well you can't tell the
guy who did the thing that no one said
could be done that he has to act a
little more like you would act yeah
because most likely you didn't
accomplish and you probably said this
too I don't have to go back and look but
my guess is you're like some of our some
of the smart political people we have
that that work with us I don't think
anyone else could have beat Hillary
Clinton in 2016. no he was the only one
that could have done it the only one who
could have done it imagine if we had her
there we'd have had the same thing we
had on Biden for two years we've been
living under that for four years for
goodness look the simple truth is no
matter whether he runs or not or becomes
president again or not or whatever like
we owe the guy a massive debt of
gratitude all of the truth that we're
now seeing whether we can do anything
with it or not yeah it is in large part
because of him it's in large part
because of you thank you my friend it's
been because of you thanks for what
you're doing those sleeps you're
freaking me out with those here we go
for the last for the last two seconds
right last two seconds Jim Jordan
rolling his sleeves
awesome thank you thank you yeah if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell